Speaker 1: OK, one thing I do want to go back
to is the crazy decision that Larry Elder made
before his humiliating defeat in California to
start claiming voter fraud before we even had
the election results. He saw the writing on the
wall. And this is also a very Trumpy approach now,
a very Trumpy in tactic say it's rigged. If I
didn't win, it must have been rigged because
a true election, a fair election, an honest
election would have resulted in me winning.
This is the approach. And I want to remind
people we should not forget that this is what
they did. This is an article from yesterday.
Larry Elder prepares for a California recall
loss with lawyers and a voter fraud Web site.
With less than a week to go until the California
recall, some Republicans are falsely claiming
votes are rigged in favor of Democrats and
suggesting without evidence that governor Governor
Gavin Newsom can only win with fraudulent votes.
The claims are unsubstantiated and echo similar
false messages promoted by Republicans last year
following the election of President Joe Biden. We
wondered if this would be the new tactic applied
to any election they lose. And so far the answer
is yes. Larry Elder, the top polling Republican,
is already planning to challenge the recall
results if Newsom survives. Elder told
reporters in Los Angeles on Wednesday he believes
they're very there might very well be shenanigans,
but he expects to win anyway. Elder said his
campaign nevertheless is ready to file lawsuits
and encourage people to report any issues.
We have a voter integrity board all set up.
Most of these are lawyers. We're going to
file lawsuits in a timely fashion. A link
on Elders' campaign website labeled as report
election incident took. Whoa, sorry about that.
Took users. To a forum to report incidents of
voter fraud and sign a petition to investigate
the results of the recall, understand that
they had a petition to investigate the results
two days before there were any results. Now,
after we reported this yesterday and so did the
Sacramento Bee and others, they changed
the site, OK, they removed the petition
to do an investigation of the results, apparently
realizing it looks really bad to do that before
there were actually any results. Now we also
have clips reminding us of their strategy.
Here is an interview that Jacob Soboroff
from MSNBC did with Larry Elder on Monday,
multiple times asking Larry Elder, will
you commit to accepting the results? And
Larry Elder was slippery, to say the
Speaker 2: least, to Larry Elder,
the leading Republican candidate would not
commit to accepting the results of the election.
Again, whether or not you win or lose, will you
accept the results of the election tomorrow?
I think we all ought to be looking at election
integrity, no matter whether you're a Democrat
and independent or Republican. Let's all make sure
that the election is a fair election. So let's
all work together, no matter what the results
are, to make sure that the results are valid
and legitimate. And everybody who voted should
have voted. Let's all do that together. Is
that a commitment to accept the results of the
election tomorrow? I'll do that together. Let's
all work together on both sides of the aisle to
make sure that the election is a fair election.
Speaker 1: Now, to his credit, Larry Elder
did concede last night or early this morning.
And based on what we know right now, this
might change in the next couple of hours.
Based on what we know right now, it doesn't
actually seem like he's going to be pushing
anything. And part of the reason why is when
you lose so overwhelmingly, so humiliatingly,
what is even the plausible mathematical case
for this? Not that there really was one with
Trump and Biden either, but this is just a
different this is a different animal altogether.
Trump was also getting ahead of this by saying
in advance, this was last week, that it it
seems they already rigged it in California,
Speaker 2: got the recall election coming up
in less than a week. It's actually happening
as we speak. The polls appear to show Newsom
looks safer at this point. Larry Elder
is the man that could take it from him.
What do you think happens in California?
Speaker 3: Well, it's probably rigged.
They're sending out all ballots. All the
ballots are, you know, mail out mail in
ballots. In fact, I guess you even have a
case where you can make your own ballot.
When that happens, nobody's going to win
except these Democrats. So, you know, look,
they're very good. The one thing they're good
at is rigging elections. So I predict it's a
rigged election. Let's see how it turns out.
Speaker 1: So this is the same playbook. I mean,
it's not just Larry Elder using the same
playbook as Trump. Even Trump was involved
in using the same playbook and applying it to
the California gubernatorial recall. So in terms
of Larry Elder actually getting a petition going
for voter fraud investigation before the election,
maybe they accidentally published the page too
early, or maybe not. And then once they realized
this looks really disastrous, we're going to pull
the page down. But it is increasingly clear that
this is going to be a tactic for Republicans
for some period of time. It will be really
interesting to see. And, you know, there's
so much up in the air about the November 22
midterms. If they get crushed in November of
22 Republicans, that is, they will have trouble
pulling the it was all rigged thing because
it's just going to be like, come on again, guys,
you're just losing and you're losing badly. If
it's close or Republicans narrowly take the House,
but not by that much, they will start arguing,
hey, you know what? We took the house by three.
We really should have taken it by 40. But they
rigged so many elections. So I believe this
tactic is going to rear its ugly head again. And
when you can't win on policy, you try to go with
that homonyms and then claim that they stole the
election for you. Let me know your thoughts. How
long is this going to be the Republican tactic?
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman